there they are friend follow me  oh God sorry Frank sorry strong form  my name is Dr Lily Houghton my brother  and I are looking for passage upriver  what's out there in the jungle it's not  a fun vacation well I'm not here for a  vacation Legend has it that there is a  tree that possesses unparalleled healing  power it will change medicine forever  and you need someone to help you find it  here we go  sometimes it just needs a bit of a  nobody touches my engine but me  what did I just do  there you go  we're gonna do this together  haven't you been dreaming about  Adventure  chasing after some far-fetched idea  everything that you see wants to kill  you and can  [Music]  you want to turn back nope just getting  started  foreign  [Music]  foreign  [Applause]